hello I'm Taryn Edgerton and this is how
I became Elton John the first time I
remember being aware of him I was very
young and it would have been when the
Lion King came out and you'd like most
people of my generation was quite
enchanted by their film and he kind of
cropped up quite a lot during my time
growing up my falling in love with music
when I was a should for drama school
when I was 17 and 18 because I didn't
get in the first year I sang your song
as my performance piece so he sort of
always been there and I've always been
fascinated by Elton you know he's
someone who's notoriously a huge
personality and notoriously kind of can
be tricky and I always found that very
appealing the first time I met him was
on Kingsman and we were shooting it
there's a scene in the movie where I get
married and he was should've up at the
piano or the organ you know in the kind
of pulpit bit as you can tell I'm not
I'm not particularly familiar with
churches but he kind of asked me to go
up and say hello to him and he said you
know if I was five years younger it'd be
me you were getting married to now which
which made me blush actually it was the
first thing I would imagine somewhere in
the region of five or six hundred times
and there's now made me blush because he
enjoys that the genesis of Rocketman
probably happens somewhere around that
time for whatever reason the film in its
iteration before that had a different
actor attached and I think he'd been
very busy and just too much time at
elapsed and Matthew Vaughn sort of
joined forces without Anand David and
their to production companies to try and
set it up and Matthew asked me one day
on Kingsman how do you feel about
playing up John and I knew that I wanted
to do something that would utilize my
singing because I sing of it and he's
also just a fascinating character you
know he's one of the most extraordinary
most creative people that's ever lived I
think so I was very very excited to be
asked so I said yeah let's do it
so basically Matthew set up this day at
Abbey Road where they put me in front of
a piano and I sang two songs I sang your
song and I sang don't let the Sun go
down on me and they recorded me doing it
and I was wearing an old vintage Elton
tee that David Furnish found in the
archive so that was as near as I got to
an order
which I suppose it was in a way I didn't
know it was I thought I already had it
becoming him was all about just of
immersing myself in his worlds really I
wouldn't spend some time at his house
with him
I read his Diaries I tended to sort of
glean what I could glean from him really
as that was the most reliable
information and then a lot of time spent
in studio working on his songs with
Charles Martin and finding different
interpretations of them some of them
some we do more faithfully because we
have songs in the film that were users
so in musical theater moments where they
songs move the plot forward or reveal
something about how a character's
feeling but also we use songs as part of
the soundtrack so my kind of disembodied
voice will just chime up at certain
moments which is quite fun too
at the start of the process was Rocket
Man Elton was very keen that I find a
grit and a gravel to my voice and
something that felt more authentically
rock and roll and he also wanted me to
find my own take on the songs and not to
try and emulate him too much which was
hard at first because I feel like
there's a lot of pressure to emulate I'm
glad we didn't I like to sing ballads
and I find that quite comfortable but
finding a rockier part of my voice was
quite a challenge and sounds like
Saturday Night's Alright for fighting
and the pinball wizard and Benny in the
Jets and getting that grit into your
voice and making it sound like rock and
roll but not like musical theatre the
remotes I think when I evoke a sense of
him but because I do all the singing you
know it'd be sounds more like me even if
those out but immersing myself in the
world of his music was the thing that
made me feel most close to him like a
lot of people you know albums music or I
should say Alton and Bernie's music to
be more accurate makes me feel stuff so
you know when you are playing someone
and you're using their music as part of
the storytelling feels more acutely
emotional than that I would say I spent
about three months learning the piano
and I'm still not very good because it
turns out it takes longer than three
months who'd have thought it but what we
did achieve was we would work on the
songs and focus largely on rhythm and
placing of your hands along the keys so
that unless it's a very unforgiving
angle you're more able to
invest in the idea that it's me playing
I won't pretend that all the playing in
the film because that would be silly
most of it's done by an incredible
pianist named dave hartley but I think I
fake it quite well I hope by saying a
song with Elton at their Oscar viewing
party for the e Jeff Foundation and it
was an incredible experience it was very
very daunting and very scary but also
incredible and it was quite an emotional
thing and he played the song very very
beautifully and it's just an experience
I'll remember forever
forever and ever and ever and I felt
very supported by him and very looked
after by him it was a lovely thing
[Music]